we want to be able to protect
every single person in eastern oklahoma
regardless of their race the state
should be able to prosecute those crimes
and right now we just simply have lost
that jurisdiction so we're asking the
supreme court for the authority to
protect law and order in eastern
oklahoma
[Music]
[Music]
we have lost the ability as a state to
prosecute crimes when there's a when
there's a native victim we're trying to
protect native victims in this case
so we've got to be able to do that as a
state if we're going to be a
if we're going to protect law and order
the state of oklahoma
we have crimes without punishment
we have victims without justice
we if somebody steals the car of a
native american
they might as well forget it because
there's no law enforcement that's going
to be able to come and help them
because the state of oklahoma can't
and the feds are prioritizing murders
rapes child abuse
and not property crimes we're having to
ask the united states supreme court
whether the state of oklahoma can
prosecute non-indians who commit crimes
on indians in indian country
which is
all six reservations
the eastern 43 percent of the state of
oklahoma so this is an incredibly
important this uh hearing tomorrow
i think the justices were very engaged
with
the arguments here and because we're
confident that we're right on the law
i'm confident that
the justices will
see it our way
and i think they were also very
concerned about i think what one justice
said was the unsustainable situation on
the ground in oklahoma so they're very
familiar both with
the correctness of our legal arguments
as well as
the unfortunate situation happening down
in oklahoma the federal government was
arguing that indians are wards of the
federal government
i take offense to that personally
i don't need to be a ward of the federal
government in oklahoma
we've never had reservations and so i
think oklahomans would be really
interesting to to think about that
that if you federalize our state and
make it a federal enclave that's
basically what they're saying
heck no i mean we're we're independent
we're god-fearing we're u.s citizens uh
we're on equal footing with every other
citizen in the united states and for
them to call us a war to the federal
government i don't think that's what
oklahomans want in eastern part of our
state
[Music]